wo ist dein weg
sie können eine ausbildung beginnen oder
studieren ohne gute bis sehr gute
deutschkenntnisse geht das nicht aber so
wie ich das sehe haben sich schon viele
deutsch gelernt
[Musik]
gonzales tschuldigung könnten sie das
bitte noch einmal wiederholen
ich habe gesagt dass sie für viele
ausbildungsberufe oder ein studium gute
bis sehr gute deutschkenntnisse brauchen
ich habe gerade mit b1 niveau angefangen
das klingt gut
haben sie die a2 prüfung gemacht aber
ich habe einen arzt bei kurs gemacht ich
bin mir sicher dass sie das kann aber
ich bin mir auch sicher dass die meisten
betriebe einen nachweis über ihre
deutschkenntnisse verlangen
dafür müssen sie eine sprachprüfung
machen okay da mache ich diese
sprachprüfung und dann kann ich eine
ausbildung machen
mal sehen welchen beruf möchten sie denn
lernen
ich bin mir nicht sicher sie sind sich
unsicher
gibt es eine schauspielausbildung sie
können in deutschland eine
schauspielschule besuchen
aber da gibt es eine sehr schwere
aufnahmeprüfung
niemand kann ihnen garantieren dass sie
nach der ausbildung auch als
schauspieler arbeiten können die
situation auf dem arbeitsmarkt ist für
schauspieler sehr schwierig habe ich
schon gehört
sie können es natürlich versuchen haben
sie denn vielleicht noch andere
interessen oder gibt es etwas das sie
sehr gut kann ja ich kann fahrräder und
mopeds reparieren
[Musik]